nice to see you very nice to see you
morgan with eg canada um so i see it
it's date night with you and your man
monson over there do you want to get him
in here yeah absolutely do you want to
come in
i see you hanging out here first of all
congratulations uh i see that shiny ring
can i see the race it looked beautiful
you searched well
you did good
um so listen i have to ask you got
engaged in paris the engagement party
was paris themed are we having a wedding
in france
maybe maybe maybe
yeah how's the wedding planning going um
we don't have any plans yet we just got
engaged so yeah uh actually we're just
on tour right now both guys together on
the bite me tour here in canada we're
like seven shows in and then made a stop
for the junos and tonight i'm performing
a medley of golden new songs and happy
to be here
oh i've always wanted to this is awesome
yeah okay so does the stereotype ring
true are canadians the nicest oh my god
yeah all the the pictures over here i
was like no one's even screaming
pretty different we just say please a
lot um
photographers are very polite yes like
okay listen i have to tell you everybody
i've interviewed is so excited that
you're here tonight they've all told me
how much you have influenced their
careers like i'm not kidding you like
everyone's talking about you being here
um how does that make you feel and being
you know that this is the 20th
anniversary of your debut album to have
so many people so excited to see you oh
that's so sweet that makes me feel good
thank you
but yeah it's a really special year with
it being the 20th anniversary since the
first album let go and yeah and tonight
i get to perform like a medley of some
three songs from the first album and
then my new single bite maybe
love sucks records that's awesome
the last time i performed at the junos
was with my song girlfriend oh my god
i'm forever again awesome to be here
that's amazing and you get to see how
much canada is obsessed with her right
oh it's been crazy every night
we're obsessed with canada like the
shows on this tour have just been so
amazing in the fans and i feel so
grateful listen it's so cool that you're
here tonight